We have really bad news.
Uh, United Kingdom is cancelling visas
for the family members.
It means if you
in the past were going to study in England
and you would want to bring your children
or your spouse,
you can forget about it.
Unfortunately,
UK is cutting down on the family reunion visas
and that's big shock
because normally what students would do
is they would come to study full time
and their dependent would come
learn the language and work full time
to make sure that the family can move together.
It's not possible anymore.
But the good news is that luckily
there is always an alternative.
Because of Brexit,
education in UK has been really,
really chaotic.
So we found out different solutions,
different other countries where you could go
where the family would still be accepted.
For the solution,
you need to watch the video number two.